Now, let's finish this.
Watch these two miracles. Matthew
8:23-27.
And he got into the boat. His disciples
followed him. A windstorm arose on the
sea.
So great that the boat was being swamped
by the waves, but he was asleep. And
they went and woke him up, saying,
"Lord, save us. We are perishing."
Remember the language. If you look at
the Greek, it's identical as well. And
he said to them, "Why are you afraid?
You of little faith." Then he got up,
rebuked the winds and the sea, there was
a dead calm. Now watch your reaction.
They're amazed, saying, "What sort of
man is this that even the winds in the
sea obey him?" See, now they know their
Old Testament.
Why do they react this way? Because they
know their Old Testament. And by the
way, this is in Mark as well. You'll
find this in Mark. Mark chapter 4 35-41.
This is found in Mark. Mark 4:35-41.
And the story of Matthew 14 is found in
Mark 6:45-52. Now watch where I'm going
with this.
They knew their Old Testament. The way
he effortlessly
commands the winds and waves and they
immediately obey, immediately go silent,
showing that even creation recognizes
the voice of the creator. Unlike the
part of creation, sentient beings who
though God will be in their midst, they
either don't acknowledge him or don't
recognize him.
Okay? Now watch.
Now watch here the other passage.
Immediately Matthew 14:22-33,
he made the disciples get into the boat
and go on ahead to the other side. while
he dismissed the crowds. And after he
had dismissed the crowds, he went up the
mountain by himself to pray. When
evening came, he was there alone. But by
this time, the boat battered by the
waves, was far from the land, for the
wind was against them. And early in the
morning, he came walking toward them on
the sea. But when the disciples saw him
walking on the sea, they were terrified,
saying, "It is a ghost." They cried out
in fear. But immediately Jesus spoke to
him and said, "Take heart. It is I."
Literally, "Egoy,
ego, I am." Now, this is important
because they're going to lie to you.
Now, God logic, I need you to listen to
this. They'll say, "Why is it that only
John records the ego ami statements of
Christ?" If Jesus said it, why don't we
find it in the other gospels? They're
lying to you. It is found.
Matthew 14:22-33,
Mark 6:45-52,
John 6:16-21,
all three record the same miracle.
It's an I am saying of Jesus.
John 6:20,
right? Matthew 14:27,
Mark 6:50, all record the same words.
Take heart ego.
You do find an ego amy statement of
Jesus
that is recorded in John in Matthew and
Mark. So they're lying to you when they
say they don't record ego statements of
Christ. Yes, they do. Matthew and Mark
record the same ego statement of Christ
found in John 6:16-21
in relation to the same miracle. Walking
on water.
We got it.
Rumble. We got it.
Okay. Do not be afraid. Peter answers
him, Lord, if it is you, command me to
come to you on the water. He said, come.
So Peter got out of the boat, started
[clears throat] walking on the water,
came toward Jesus. But when he noticed
the strong wind, he became frightened.
Beginning sink, he cried out, "Lord,
save me." Pay attention to this. Jesus
immediately reached out his hand and
caught him, saying to him, "You of
little faith. Why did you doubt?" When
they got into the boat, the wind seized,
and those in the boat worshiped him,
saying, "Truly, you are the son of God."
Now, how do I know they're worshiping
him as God? Note, they know he's not the
father.
They know he's a son of the father. He's
a son of God. But how do I know he
they're worshiping him as the divine son
of God, not simply honoring him. Watch.
Lord, save me.
Lord, command me to come to you on the
water. Notice, give me the ability,
authorize me, empower me to walk on
water. Meaning,
you have the ability
to enable us to walk on water. You're
the source of that power
that we need to walk on water. All
right. Also, he said, "Egoy me." And
watch here. Lord, save us. We're
perishing when they thought the boat
would capsize. Rebuke the winds and the
sea. And there is that calm. What sort
of man is this that even the winds and
sea obey him? Now watch the Old
Testament background.
Job 98.
See, they knew their Old Testament.
They knew their Old Testament. That's
why they wondered, "Who is this man? Why
does he do what our Bible says God does,
such as who alone stretched out the
heavens and trampled the ways of the
sea?" God alone has sovereign power
to subjugate the elements, the winds,
and the waves. But that's the same power
Jesus had to enable Peter to trample on
the water.
First connection. Psalm 65:5-8.
By your awesome deeds, you answer
us with deliverance. Oh God of our
salvation. You are the hope of all the
ends of the earth and of the farthest
seas. By your strength, you establish
the mountains. You are gir might. Now
watch. You silence the roaring of the
seas. the roaring of the waves and the
tumult of the people's meaning when
people panic you silence and quiet them
wait these very three thing three things
he does in Matthew look
they're panicking Lord save us we are
perishing he rebukes the winds and the
sea silence them and there's that calm
and he also calms their frenzy
that's why they say Who is this man? How
is it he does what the Old Testament
says God does? How is it even the winds,
the waves, the seas know to obey his
voice?
You see what he did? He did what Psalm
65 5-8 says Yahweh does.
Not not getting it.
And he's the one who said, "I am." Now,
watch this one here. This one is a
doozy. This one right here. But let's
read this. Psalm 77:19 to20. Your way
was through the sea. Your path through
the mighty waters. Yet your footprints
were unseen. You led your people like a
flock by the hand of Moses and Aaron. So
Jesus walks on water as God walks on
water. And God walks on water as you
walk on dry ground.
And who enables people to walk on water?
Jesus. Because Peter said, "Lord, if
it's real you, then you have the ability
to enable me to walk on water." Notice
he says you. He didn't say pray to your
father. You have that command and
authority to do it, to make me walk on
water. All right, go ahead.
But you thought that was the deepest
connection. No, this is the deepest one.
Psalm 107. You can read from 21 to 32,
but usually I begin at 22.
Let them offer thanksgiving sacrifices.
tell of his deeds with songs of joy.
Some went down to the sea and ships,
doing business on the mighty waters.
What were the apostles? Fishermen who
did business in the mighty waters.
They saw the deeds of the Lord Yahawah,
the word of Jehovah. His windworks in
the deep. They saw him do miracles in
the sea. For he commanded and raised the
stormy wind, which lifted up the waves
of the sea. Now watch. They mounted up
to heaven. They went down to the depths.
Their courage melted away in their
calamity. They reeled and staggered like
drunkards and were at their wits end.
They were terrified, horrified, thinking
they're going to capsize.
So what did they do? They saw the Lord
Jehovah do miracles for them in the sea.
Then they cried to the Lord in their
trouble, and he brought them out out of
their distress. He made the storm be
still and the waves
of the sea were hushed. Then they were
glad because they had quiet and he
brought them to their zide haven. Watch
the bold parts.
Let them thank the Lord for his
steadfast love for his wonderful works
to humankind. Let them extol him in the
congregation people and praise him
assembly of the elders. Now watch.
He's made the storm still. He hushed the
waves of the sea when they cried out to
the Lord Jehovah after they were afraid,
reeling back and forth like drunken men
and were terrified that they're about to
capsize. But then they saw the Lord do
miracles in the sea when he silenced the
wind and the waves. Who? The Lord. Who
did they cry out to? The Lord. Who?
Jehovah. Who did they praise after he
delivered them? The Lord Jehovah. That's
exactly what Jesus did.
Those in the boat worshiped him, saying,
"Truly, you're a son of God." When when
the wind seized and he brought them to
their desired haven in peace, who did
they cry out to save me? The Lord Jesus.
Who told them, "Don't be afraid. It's
me." The Lord Jesus. Who did they cry to
when they thought they were going to
capsize because the winds of the waves?
The Lord Jesus. Lord, save us. We are
perishing. Who rebuked the winds and the
waves and silence them? The Lord Jesus.
Let's cray cray
cray cray.
You got the article, brother.
And this also is an older article.
It's not one of these notes. See, I when
I tell you guys 98 to 99% of your
objections have been answered, it's
right here.
Sink it in.